hundreds of fans gathered at  Invercargill airport on Thursday the  third of sep tember to give a big south  and welcome to a trio of All Blacks  verdun college students performed a  rousing Hucker to welcome the players as  they enter the terminal while Matata  school students also performed cultural  presentations inspirational captain  Richie McCaw along with Colin Slade and  wyatt crockett arrived in the south to  visit matata school as part of the All  Blacks to the nation competition excited  fans Clement for photos and it was clear  who they had come to see with cheers  erupting when the plane touched down and  an announcement over the airport PA  system cried Ritchie and bookable fans  were excited to welcome them as they  arrived in the deep south  you